[Música]
nos últimos anos trouxe ano realmente
uma quantidade grande enorme de
tecnologia para as pessoas que têm
deficiência essas tecnologias fizeram um
aumento incrível nas potencialidades dos
indivíduos
por exemplo aqui a gente vê o conjunto
de ferramentas
o dois lotes que a nossa ferramenta mais
antiga que hoje tem mais de 100 mil
usuários que permite que uma pessoa cega
e inscreva elenco o computador
acesse a internet jogue né
temos aqui é próteses de vários tipos
que são fabricados no brasil são
importadas que usaria direita uma pessoa
cega caminhando e nova york
totalmente livre sem ninguém do lado
dela com sua bengala só para me preparar
em um buraco mas ela está sendo guiada
por um gps que vai indicando a cada
momento qual é o caminho que ela tem que
seguir e os obstáculos que ela tem que
evitar ali embaixo o implante coclear
dando uma criança que nasceu talvez até
com a 100 na copa a parte externa do
ouvido a potencialidade de escutar minha
mulher é tetraplégica e ela usa uma
cadeira de rodas como essa que dá a ela
mais velocidade do que eu ela ela fala
se vai devagar
então e ali uma criança com paralisia
cerebral utilizando bom
a quantidade de tecnologia que existe
hoje é imensa ea tecnologia que faz
basicamente é fazer superar as
limitações que as pessoas têm
elas nascem ou adquirem uma deficiência
e essa deficiência faz com que ela tenha
limitações mas será que essas limitações
são assim tão definitivas e aí a gente
começa fazendo uma pergunta será que uma
pessoa cega por uma pessoa que não tenha
nascido com os olhos ela consegue ler um
livro escrito a tinta
sim através dos vox o computador ler pra
ela através de um scanner aquele livro é
transcrito ela consegue ler o turnê mas
hoje em dia têm tecnologias muito mais
sofisticadas aqui um senhor idoso com
uma catarata totalmente inoperável
um livro na sua frente e um óculos
mágico chamado por kan
esse óculos dá essa pessoa a habilidade
de apontar simplesmente apontar para o
livro e para onde apontar uma máquina
ela está ilustrada e fica presa na
cintura da pessoa recebe dos óculos
a imagem aquilo interpretado e aquela
informação então é lida em voz alta e
faz mais do que isso a pessoa tem
andando pela rua ela percebe uma pessoa
não sabe quem é
aperta o botão zinho ea máquina fala
antônio borges reconhece fácil reconhece
cartazes
aí eu pergunto ele é cego
se eu não souber que ele é cego ele
chega pra mim no meio da rua e fala o
antônio
como é que ele sabe que sou eu ele é
cego
será que um paraplégico
uma pessoa com paraplegia e sabem que a
paraplegia os membros inferiores não se
movimentam esse movimento e forma
extremamente precária
o paraplégico pode caminhar
bom a gente já sabe que cadeira de rodas
poderiam ser utilizadas mas hoje em dia
pernas robóticas fazem com que ele
caminho perfeitamente direto com
velocidade pela rua ele pode correr com
essas pernas ele naquele momento ele não
é paraplégico ele é só uma pessoa
uma pessoa que tem umas pernas um
pouquinho diferentes até 6 charmosas que
podem ser confundidos com uma calça com
uma listra branca do lado o deputado que
tenha como perdido as duas pernas pode
dançar
claro que pode vocês todos viram vocês
viram a m
aí me uma bailarina americana que veio
as paraolimpíadas aqui no rio de janeiro
e dançou com o robô lembrando essa cena
maravilhosa e sambou até então tá aí eu
pergunto as limitações são definitivas
não elas não são definitivas
então essa definição de é paraplégico é
paraplégico e caminhávamos peraí
se ele é paraplégico a própria definição
de paraplégico indica que ele não
caminha então com ele é paraplégico e
caminha é uma definição que é baseada em
uma limitação só que essa definição hoje
não funciona mais
o que é caminhar o que é ler o que é
dançar é preciso ler com os olhos
é preciso caminhar com os músculos é
preciso dançar com o com que com essas
definições hoje já se relativizam é
deficiente ou não é deficiente
bom até a tecnologia ela faz parte do
seu corpo
ou ela não faz parte do seu corpo ela
faz sim ela a pessoa passa a utilizar a
tecnologia como se aquilo fosse o corpo
dela e ela se acostuma de tal maneira
que se um dia aquela tecnologia for
tirada dela aí sim ela vai sentir aponta
amputada a elas que se ela vai sentir
cega aí sim ela vai sentir deficiente
aí eu faço uma pergunta imagina agora o
corredor com pernas biônicas ou não sei
vocês talvez tenha ouvido falar em
pistorius um corredor
quis disputar nas olimpíadas não nas
paraolimpíadas
ele queria correr com suas pernas feitas
em led que substância de danny ou alguma
coisa desse tipo e que dava a essa
pessoa
uma habilidade de correr ele queria
correr ele queria correr não sei nos 200
metros não sei qual é onde ele queria
correr mas ele queria correr junto com
as pessoas que têm pernas com um pernas
normais
então aí eu pergunto eu corredor com
pernas
eu to falando biônica nós podia ser
qualquer coisa quando fala biônica tá
pensando em eletrônica as pernas não são
bonitas elas são pernas
sei lá de que tipo né mas imagina pernas
ainda mais sofisticadas do que aquele
corredor pernas biônicas então se esse
corredor disputar com o correr do
corredor com pernas de carne e ele
vencer é justo
será que o fato de ele ser um ser humano
e que coloca o artefato e esse artefato
faz dele uma pessoa ser uma pessoa
normal
ou será um super humano mas na verdade
essa questão de corridas de olimpíadas
ela cheia de coisas duvidosas por
exemplo vocês já devem ter ouvido falar
de um lavador alguns anos atrás que
venceu a olimpíada porque estava usando
uma roupa uma roupa que diminuir o
atrito com a água e com isso ele
conseguia vencer não é o mesmo caso este
nadador não foi questionado
será que a pessoa com deficiência deixa
através do uso da tecnologia de ser - e
passa a ser mais olha que coisa estranha
a pessoa era menos pela deficiência e
você colocou tecnologia e ela foi
rechaçada por que ela é mais
que coisa mais estranha é bom os limites
entre u é sem dúvida os limites e
ampliou ea gente não se dá conta com
isso tem sido muito rápido
e aí eu vou dar um exemplo de como isso
pode ser perverso na medida que os
limites se ampliam os grupos sociais nos
quais essa pessoa está envolvida começam
a cobrar dessa pessoa
ou seja o grupo social percebe que
aquela pessoa não é mais aquela pessoa
antiga ou seja os feridos gerado pela
carne mais tecnologia passa a ser
percebido socialmente ea pessoa então é
mais cobrado
eu vou dar um exemplo para que tornar
para que se torne bem claro
imagina por exemplo ano de 1501 ano 1500
o que aconteceu
o brasil foi descoberto tinha cegos ali
na corte portugal em portugal na espanha
tinha cegos tinhas óbvio que tinha cegos
muitos desses servos mendigos outros não
eram vendidos outros eram filhos de
alguma família e tinha tido alguma
doença se feliz sei lá que doença e
tenham ficado ser bom dia certo como é
que esses egos se comunicavam só começa
falando eles não podiam escrever
tá certo porque naquela época não tinha
se essa facilidade de escrever então
alguém chega e 1.500 falar assim mas
peraí ele não vale tanto assim ele nem
escreve ele só lê bom
passam se os anos passam se 350 anos e
um francês
o sérvio também inventou um método
chamado braille e que aí o cego consegue
ler claro ler pontinhos e alguém chega
assim mas peraí não está lendo e talento
além do diferente está escrevendo
diferente
e aí passam se os anos e surge o
computador em 1990
e aí o computador através do docs por
exemplo que nasceu em 1993 permite que
se segue escreva igual aos outros e aí
alguém chegasse impera a irmã dele
escreve mas ele não escreve na internet
estão percebendo ele ganha e logo em
seguida ele perde
e aí em 2000 o docs introduz os
primeiros programas de internet do
brasil e aí ele pode fazer chat fazem
sexo virtual só acessar sei lá o quê
e alguém chega para mas ele não desenha
ele não vê gráficas não vê mulher pelada
na tela do computador bom ea em 2010
macros são criadas para permitir que ele
leia desenhos escreva e produza desenhos
e alguém chega assim mas ele não pilota
o avião e aí um cego chamado wagner maia
tira um brevê de piloto pela microsoft
no simulador de vôo
ele só não pode voar porque a legislação
não permite
qual é o limite disso pode ser na
verdade ir tão longe quanto siqueira é
uma um fraque tal é um mandril groth que
vai se você vai fazendo aquilo vai se
ampliando se ganha se questiona se ganha
se questiona um ciclo infinito quando o
limite
aparentemente intransponível é
transposto logo a sociedade impõe um
outro limite e às vezes com maior
exigência ou com maior cobrança
então eu pergunto qual é o limite da
deficiência
aí essa pergunta pode soar estranha e
vou fazer uma pequena mudança nessa
palavra deficiência
eu vou botar um parêntese nesse de qual
é o limite da entre parentes de
eficiência porque é isso que a
tecnologia está produzindo ela está
produzindo eficiência e eu pergunto mais
quem é esse ser humano sobre o qual e se
esse limite se aplica
eu te digo não é um ser humano é o
híbrido é um híbrido da carne com a
tecnologia é um híbrido da alma com a
tecnologia
e aí como consideração final o que
define uma pessoa com deficiência
quando a própria definição de
deficiência com o uso da tecnologia se
torna ambígua
[Música]